in the middle east the ceasefire between
hamas and
israel is still holding this morning and
president biden
has told his secretary of state to go
there this week
holly williams is in gaza which took the
brunt of the violence during the 11-day
conflict that ended thursday
even though the bombing of gaza has
stopped the devastation
is staggering good morning
this gives you a sense of the sheer
force of the israeli airstrikes
this was two apartment buildings they've
both been completely leveled
and locals tell us more than 40 people
died here the israeli strikes also
damage the gaza strips infrastructure
and many people here are now struggling
to get clean running water
and reliable electricity sarah is
four years old and has a spinal injury
collateral damage in a war she's too
young to understand
[Music]
we felt an explosion over our heads i
picked her up and ran into the street
her mother lena told us what did she do
to deserve this
this is sarah before the 11-day conflict
now her doctors say she'll never walk
again
her father zaher is living every
parent's worst nightmare
he couldn't protect his own child
as israelis and palestinians descended
into violence once again
more than 250 people lost their lives
the vast majority of them here in the
gaza strip
where officials say almost 70 of those
killed were children
on the streets of gaza they're still
sifting through the wreckage of
splintered homes
and lives and yet hamas
celebrated the ceasefire with a victory
parade
they governed the gaza strip and are
classed by the us
as a terrorist organization
israel says more than 4 000 rockets were
fired at its towns and cities
killing 12 civilians and we do have
one small piece of good news for you
sarah's family have told us that they
are expecting that she'll be evacuated
today
to get medical treatment in jordan
that's holly williams reporting from
gaza